we begin with this us is grounding all
Boeing 737 max Jets after investigators
found similarities between two deadly
crashes involving the aircraft in the
past five months
the FAA issued an emergency order
yesterday telling airlines to stop
flying the planes more than three days
after 737 max eight crashed in Ethiopia
157 people on board were killed in
October 189 people were killed when an
eight when a 737 max eight crashed in
Indonesia Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan
National Airport outside Washington
where he spoke to the Acting FDA
Administrator Chris good morning good
morning for three days the FAA resisted
calls and mounting pressure to ground
the 737 max even though a growing list
of countries did just that well that all
changed yesterday based on some new
evidence that has surfaced this morning
we asked the acting FAA Administrator
Daniel Elwell about that evidence
linking potentially linking the two
crashes and whether it is safe whether
it was safe to keep the plane in the sky
after the Indonesia crash last October
the airplane pitched up and down at a
point in the in the flight profile that
was the key was establishing that the
point at which the pitch up and pitched
down happened was very similar there are
people wondering if tens of thousands
Americans a day were on an unsafe
airplane if we knew there was a software
fix needed it wasn't done should this
action have been taken
in October or November or last year if
it was an unsafe airplane it wouldn't be
certified we're confident in the safety
of the airplane what we don't know is if
there's a linkage between those two
accidents and now that we have the new
evidence to suggest there very well
maybe we grounded the airplanes to find
the linkage southwest american united
all fly versions of the 737 max
accounting for about 280 total flights a
day the airlines are working to rebook
customers they're waiving fees but there
will be some cancellations because of
this grounding order boeing says it is
confident in the safety of the max but
does support the decision by the FAA
Boeing says out of an abundance of
caution
biana yeah there were millions of
Americans who also support that decision
- Chris thank you